but we have to begin with the news the
breaking news overnight and it is not
good yet again a mass shooting in these
United States this one happened at a
Virginia Walmart late last night as
people were shopping before the holidays
we know at this hour at least six people
were killed and police say the shooter
is also dead seven dead total Chesapeake
Virginia is only the latest City in town
big places small places in this country
to face this kind of violence and our
Jeff begaze has made his way to the
scene Jeff good morning
yeah Tony the sun still isn't even up
here but this investigation has been
ongoing for more than eight hours now
and you can see the scene behind me it
is massive this morning not only because
it encompasses the Walmart itself but
also this parking lot and just in the
last few minutes you have more police
officers
investigators showing up here they know
it will be a long holiday week for them
as they try to figure out why this
gunman went on a rampage here
the emergency calls started coming in
just minutes after the shots were fired
at around 10 15 last night at the
Walmart 16 year old male is conscious is
breathing positive gunshot wound
I've heard now very serious bleeding
when officers arrived at the Chesapeake
Walmart they quickly realized that they
were dealing with a mass shooting
incident cell phone video from a man who
said he was a shopper spoke of the
horrific scene
we heard several shots inside probably
20 minutes ago
and all ran out there was a person down
that's still down out front the
so-called Walmart Super Center was set
to close about 45 minutes after the
shooting began with some customers still
arriving to pick up last minute items
ahead of the Thanksgiving holiday
located multiple fatalities and multiple
injured persons we believe it's a single
shooter and that single Shooter's
deceased at this time
the place he shot up another man says
that he was among the Walmart employees
inside the store when the shooting began
I literally walked out the break room
right
and as soon as I probably no better than
five minutes
at least five patients are being treated
at area hospitals this woman says her
brother is among the injured he actually
was shot in his side he is up talking
um
breathing
um
that they don't have a lot of details
right now
Walmart releasing a statement this
morning saying that it is shocked and
saddened by the shooting it is pledging
to cooperate with investigators Gail
all right I think about all the people
going through the trauma of witnessing
what they saw thank you very much Jeff